welcome back to new rockstars what if
just gave the mcu a new hero in captain
carter but could actor hayley atwell
return in live action form with her
union jack shield or should we limit our
hopes for marvel's what if to what if
ant-man really did blow up thanos's
booty hole from the inside please this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love i'm eric boss and
going rogue with me today is
mastertainment mt what's going on man i
have significantly less beer than usual
there was an accident it was a terrible
fire and now the beard is gone hello
everybody
but now we have faster access to that
smile and for that we're grateful
uh also with a stand-up comedian and
podcast host anastasia washington
welcome
thank you i have the same amount of
beard i usually have thank you
[Laughter]
and we brought him out of hydra deep
freeze it's off screen producer brandon
barry oh ready to comply
i have no beard except for my wife hey
oh
got it wait i don't think i supposed to
say that about
myself on the couch tonight
wow
thanks maybe for eternity
yeah
are you gonna make her sleep on the
couch because that's what that's what
happened
we're a couple from the 50s what can i
say i
it's delightful what if it's now out in
the world and we're so excited what a
premiere and we're so excited for the
episodes ahead and the producers of the
show have said that uh captain carter is
gonna be a central recurring figure on
this series she's confirmed to appear in
the second season and also in an episode
later this season we think uh and
they've indicated that what if it's
really gonna set up elements for the
live-action mcu going forward and latest
news this week what if director brian
andrews said that he and head writer ac
bradley actually want there to be a
live-action captain carter movie
so that's our question for today could
haley atwell return in live action in
the mcu as captain carter and if that's
the case would she have to get jacked
up to play this character uh could they
do it in some other way or could maybe
another variant of her play a leadership
role similar to like double 07's m but
to the captain britain core uh or could
she appear in multiverse of madness to
fight shima gorath or could she team up
with sam wilson and captain america four
what would this look what look like what
do you guys think i wanna i wanna see
her get jacked
me too we all honestly just wanna see
haley at well just get really swollen
is that not what i mean like actors have
to do it all the time she could do it
she can do it she believe in you haley
you can believe in you get in that gym
she would not need to get like
six eight you know she could just be her
height maybe do what tom cruise does in
every movie stand on an apple box uh and
then just gonna wear a slightly padded
suit and we would buy it exactly she
could get those gains on you know yeah i
was so happy to see captain carter get
big because i don't like how all the new
super soldier serums don't make you any
bigger like that's kind of the funness
of uh what made captain america so cool
was that it got big it was great seeing
a big peggy uh i think if they brought
her into like live-action uh i think
hayley atwell could like just bulk up a
little bit i mean it's a cartoon so you
kind of see it as more exaggerated right
uh but maybe they play are like older
you know uh let's say
i would wonder if they almost made a
movie where it's like a continuation of
the agent carter tv show i know they
don't like to talk about the ancient tv
shows of marvel
but i think that one was well loved i
mean they brought in
uh
jarvis we got to see him come into the
mcu so it would be really cool to kind
of make a movie as like a continuation
of that storyline you know maybe our
peggy and our universe gets to meet like
the version of her that's that got
jacked uh and it's like orphan black or
something where she gets to play like 10
variations of herself in one movie the
agent carter multiverse of madness i
would buy it yeah that would be crazy
i love that i think that
we'll probably see an agent carter or
i'm sorry captain carter in season two
of loki i think that that's a really
likely place that she'll pop up if she
does pop up in live action because loki
is a disney plus thing and as is what if
so if they were i feel like there's more
flexibility and more you can do there
with a captain carter appearance and you
know captain carter is going to be
presumably part of the the captain
britain corps which is his multiverse
team and so since loki season two ended
with the multiverse coming out and like
doing its crazy branch stuff it's highly
like it's i think it's a good chance
that we could see a captain carter
teaming up with a loki um or for some
degree or something um in season two now
do you think that uh they will connect
back to that easter egg and the episode
one of loki where there's that possibly
variant peggy carter who's being dragged
around in the background like they're
just gonna wreck on that be like yep
that was her and here she is oh yeah
like that was a huge deal when that
episode dropped it's so like if it
wasn't peggy before it's peggy now let's
that's it's peggy now so it's that's
probably what's gonna happen they're
gonna be like oh yeah that was peggy she
was on a secret mission don't you think
they test stuff like that they put stuff
like that that and then like they test
out some other kind of episode or
something and they go oh people reacted
with the way we wanted to cool that is
exactly what we wanted you know like we
did this over here
i would not be surprised at all and if
we didn't like it they're going to be
like
don't look
right oh yeah i do think that they put
easter eggs in there just to like mess
with our heads and play with our
expectations because they know like a
show like loki does not get made in a
void without like uh without youtubers
breaking it down because that show is
too complicated otherwise for general
audiences to understand it's so wild but
i think that's why the show is so great
is it like it's a show made for the fans
and the general audiences will just
catch up uh and so yeah i'm i'm not
surprised if they were to just throw in
easter eggs and be like
based off of how you break these things
down we'll decide what canon is for
season two we decide the canon we do but
really you do based on your reactions
and how much you troll us
yes
i think that's the case um now i want to
bring up the point of uh captain america
sam wilson because a falcon winter
soldier clearly ended with him being uh
captain america now we have a movie
coming out that's going to be um
made by the same showrunner following
anthony mackie in this role um i think
the mcu is big enough to have two
versions of cap a captain britain or a
captain carter and uh a captain america
as sam wilson but do would you want to
see these two in a movie together should
they be kept separate in different
universes or different continents
like so what uh how do we reconcile
these two coexisting i would like to see
captain carter show up and and fight
with like sam wilson's captain america i
mean it's it's interesting i feel like
because she is a super soldier it's like
another they love having super soldiers
and then they love taking them away
right it's like they introduce a bunch
of new super soldiers and they'll take
them away somehow or they'll be like oh
there's tons of serum and now it's all
gone again so i i could see someone
trying to get a hold of more serum and
being like there's a dimension where
peggy has the serum inside of her you
know maybe that's like how they bring in
mutants or something it's like the
mutants want to get involved with the
super soldier serum um but i would like
to see them fight together i don't think
it's too much cap for one film i mean i
think
it's just enough of the right kind of
cap for me
i don't
uh like uh steve rogers okay cool
you don't like steve rogers
fire wow
that's like something you don't see
roger's never turning out
you can't just drop that in there i mean
i've been through therapy for this so
let's just
just lay it out there um
i i'm i'm a hardcore iron man fan um
and i think that he has very selective
uh loyalties and as a team captain you
cannot have uh loyalties not to your
team but outsiders of your team instead
like i just that's not a good that's not
a good captain
you can't sacrifice your team for an
outsider not that i'm saying you can't
have friends but that's not captain
worthy you know
gotta i mean look if we're just going
back to civil war
in the first half of that movie i was
totally on a team iron man because you
got to think something like the sokovia
accord superhero registration it was a
responsible move and i think um i think
steve rogers was being selfish by
standing by his friend i specifically
did not like the justification of sharon
carter quoting peggy carter at peggy
carter's funeral and that was enough to
move uh steve rogers to be so stubborn
to say no i'm not gonna move uh whereas
you know natasha romanov was right in
front of him a living friend saying
how we stay together is not as important
as staying together like listen to the
people who are alive in your life right
now don't listen to people who affected
you decades before and their wisdom you
don't need to have mufasa clouds who
tell you what to do in your life
we do it can inform you but like that's
why i like black panther so much is like
he tells his ghost dad to f off he's
like you are not helping me anymore
right he's like i got this
right so i i agree with you there but
ultimately looking back on civil war i
think both of them were wrong i think
both of them made really stupid
decisions oh 100
yeah 100
i think it was like black panther was
just like coming in there going like i
don't know what's up with you dudes but
like maybe that's like something
yeah like i'm just like let's maybe
get it together no you guys are gonna
fight okay cool
you know
but no i just i'm i'm like super i think
it's the scorpio in me i'm a super loyal
chick and when i'd see unloyalty i uh
it's hard it's hard for me i don't know
back with with captain carter i think
that the wakandans would be really
pissed off to have like the british flag
on their vibranium shield like like with
captain america they were like you know
what it's steve rogers
but like the cop the original colonizers
putting their flag on their material
i think that would be a very interesting
what if because like i feel like okoye
would be after her like olive o'connor
would be after captain carter for their
shield back just for the principle of
the thing um so like i think i didn't
think about that but that's a very very
good point like i mean wakanda was never
colonized right it was its own uh in its
own bubble uh and it just kind of stayed
out of the events of history but like uh
t'challa especially at the end of black
panther felt this sense of
responsibility to the whole continent
and uh that was the whole theme by the
end of that movie is like we need to do
a better job protecting everyone else
who's able to learn that lesson from
killmonger and their neighboring
countries or countries like uh rwanda
uganda kenya
that have definitely experienced their
form of colonization throughout their
history and yeah the
great britain was leading that
yeah leading the charge but with regard
to this question um i think that because
we we don't know where steve rogers went
to during his like you know time travel
shenanigans after end game and because
that we're now getting you know this
captain carter wouldn't it be cool if
marvel studios is sort of like a
spider-verse situation with captain
america because now we have steve rogers
we got
sam wilson we got captain carter what if
we just like what if he just grabs a
bunch of captains he's like hey we're
the captain core we're gonna be doing
some multiverse [ __ ] uh that'd be really
fun i think it'd be great like
i i think that's the direction the
marvel cinematic multiverse needs to be
going we already have like a bunch of
loki variants in a bunch of kang
variants that we'll see with jonathan
majors um the spider verse is something
people are already familiar with from of
course the comics and into the spider
verse and hopefully we'll be seeing that
in no way home to an extent um but yeah
the captain britain core is fascinating
and uh i would love to see uh other
different legions of heroes from across
the multiverse uh and that's that's the
only way you can kind of stand up to
something like kang it's to have your
equivalent of it of your own
organization as opposed to just heroes
who are different kinds of heroes but
it's also a great way to get more people
in as these characters too
and get audiences used to having
different actors and play different
characters because i think that's like
something marvel really wants uh is that
they're not beholden to have one person
play a character in perpetuity they can
use whoever because comic book readers
get used to artistic styles changing and
characters looking different from like
story to story but it's tough in a movie
but this is like a great way to do it to
just be like well you're gonna see hero
the same hero from different universes
and he's gonna he or she's gonna look
different sometimes and it'll be great i
can accept that
let's see i am going to award a point to
uh brandon for this idea of kind of
rebooting agent carter uh because i
think that is the version of um of peggy
carter that has really worked well on
screen not enough people watch that show
you have all the actors who are on board
to do this let's just do that and i
think if you just stick to your guns on
what that show was people are gonna love
it on disney plus if you were to do that
but we have more theories that we want
to talk about from this episode of what
if um specifically where that squid
monster came from but first our merch
partners at newrockstarsmerch.com are
always dropping some cool shirts and
gear head on over to grab the most
recent latest obsession shirt bad
company inspired by the suicide squad
there's other cool suicide squad
inspired merch and some loki swag that
we still have some new designs that are
coming out all the time uh we have some
on what if that are still in the
workshop but they'll be announced soon i
can't wait for you guys to see them and
you can show your support for new rock
stars and get yourself some great nerdy
gear at new york soresmirch.com all
right uh we want to thank the sponsor of
the show wandery so if you're a fan of
new rockstars you already know who stan
lee is and the huge impact he had on
marvel comics in the entertainment
industry as a whole but what fewer fans
might know is that in the early 2000s
stan lee was actually in some financial
struggles and really on the verge of
suing marvel
the all-new season of business movers
podcast explores how stan lee changed
the comic book industry and saved his
own career in the process uh on each
season of business movers you'll hear
how titans of industry rose from the
bottom rung of the corporate ladder and
what obstacles they overcame on their
climb to the top i'm excited for this
podcast and for more people to know
about this often forgotten part of stan
lee's life on business movers you'll
find out exactly how a kid from the
bronx born at the height of the great
depression went on to become a comic
industry superhero listen to the latest
episode of business movers stan lee on
amazon music apple podcasts or you can
listen ad free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app wondering feel the
story
we also want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode our friends at
bluechew have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
showable form and at a fraction of the
cost bluechu is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discrete package you sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days their licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient and strength and if
you hate swallowing pills hey good news
blue chew is chewable just like it says
in the name so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code of rogue at checkout just
pay the five dollars in shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month free and thanks to
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
and we want to thank bespoke post so
this summer bespoke post is here to take
your adventures to the next level with a
new line up a box of awesome collections
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands to bring
you the most unique goods every month in
the past i've gotten some cool shirts
and some great kitchen gear from bespoke
post but no matter what you're into box
of awesome has you covered from travel
and outdoor gear to breezy summer styles
and groomy goods box of awesome haz
collections for every part of your life
one of their new boxes comes with
everything you need to make your own
hard cider and another one comes with a
cool looking japanese chef's knife whoa
so to get started take the quiz box of
awesome.com your answers help them pick
the right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across
different categories it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month or cancel
anytime each box costs only 45 bucks but
has over 70 worth of gear inside get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome.com and code rogue for 20 off
your first box all right let's get back
to talking about this first episode of
what if so this episode surprised many
of us by going full crazy opening up
portal through dimensions and having a
giant tentacle monster pour out into a
1940s uh castle in the middle of world
war ii in the german black forest
yeah that's my world war ii but we never
really got an answer of what dimension
this came from we thought that the space
stone opened portals in space right just
from one point of our universe to
another point of our universe what uh
einstein-rosen bridge a wormhole
this is opening a portal through
realities or through timelines or
through uh dimension uh unless there's a
planet with a bunch of squid monsters on
it but really by the end of the episode
we see peggy carter go through that
portal and end up 68 years in the future
so some natural laws were violated here
so let's speculate on what dimension
specifically these monsters could be
coming from uh could it be the dark
dimension from doctor strange maybe the
quantum realm could it be a future where
beings have conquered earth uh could it
be wherever the capitalists from
guardians volume 2 came from what do you
guys think well i think disney owns
everything now so maybe it was under the
sea and it was just ursula what
it's a
that would crowd hilarious if ursula was
the big bad of what it is it's just just
her bottom half there
she dies
oh peggy life's full of tough choices
oh peggy your man's too scrawny
you need a big bird man
exactly
see wouldn't you watch that episode
if it is another disney property it
could be twenty thousand leagues under
the sea they own that one this could be
the squid monster from that so
it could have been in space just at the
bottom of the ocean and came out no this
is probably a squid from that uh
spongebob episode where squidward goes
to that squidward community and
everyone's squidward sorry never mind oh
there it is
so angry at us he's like i'm not angry i
didn't limit into which universes and i
said i asked for ideas you guys would
give me three great ideas
this wasn't zola that made the portal
that this monster came through because
he'd been captured by that point right
so and maybe red skull knows a little
bit of tech but he was really relying on
zola before so whoever whichever
scientist stepped up to do this maybe
understood the tesseract in a way that
neither zola or selvig ever did and was
able to get it to access the new
dimension or maybe
red skull went full magic on this thing
and did some sort of weird spell that
hasn't been done yet at this point and
that's how he's able to open a dimension
because he's always into the weird
spells and the weird occult stuff
nazis be spelling who knows who made
this they do i don't they do they be
spelling all over the place they're like
[Laughter]
because zola wasn't there i feel like
zola was like more of the all right
we're going to use this as an energy
source to power weapons and like to
power you know suits and all this stuff
but like zola is out of the picture so
now um you know red skull who was more
of this guy who was like who's obsessed
about the myth of you know uh the cube
and all this stuff he's more of that
magical type person so you're probably
like you know what i'll just get a
mystic expert someone who's who's into
uh all this thor [ __ ] and he's gonna
we're gonna do something different with
the cube rather than what you know uh
hitler and hydra wants to make weapons
for it but for me i think that i this
squid definitely came from wherever that
abolis came from um in guardians 2. um i
it's probably
i think that he's from that in between
space between dimensions yeah me and
marina go into all this interdimensional
stuff in our last episode of big
question and we do talk about the space
in between dimensions and the space in
between like you know realities so i
think that these squid creatures could
just occupy that space and just be
just where they are at and they're just
it's where they're maybe just hunting
for these um
extra dimensional um
sources of energy um or just waiting to
come through a hole so yeah yeah i
definitely think that it's waiting
between
space between dimensions that um these
like really really old creatures that
have existed between the before the dawn
of a bunch of universes have uh just
been chilling and just hanging out
creatures like cheese it sounds like
what you're describing is these squid
monsters are like the the spiders and
moths that hang out right by the doors
to all of our homes just waiting for
your condition exactly air to come out
and that's how they know to come in
they're always every time a wormhole
opens the mcu it's just like right there
like now now yes
no i don't want to go there oh wait oh
that castle looks nice and then we're
just waiting for like the tastiest meals
like
all right yeah
and we didn't even see so much of it so
it's like it's like i don't even know
like there could be so much more going
on in there and i want to go in
like a top half of ursula yeah
ursula theory i really hope that it's
mega ursula with a bunch of tentacles
just a bigger version of multiverse
[Applause]
well i just noticed you know since we've
been uh since disney has bought
everything up everything's just like
thrown in there i just saw a free guy i
was like how many how many properties
are we gonna touch of disney's right now
i'm just saying it can happen well we
are all tied up before we get to rogue
questions uh we want to thank grammarly
for sponsoring this episode see when it
comes to saving time and working more
efficiently it's the little things that
start adding up and hogging time in your
day well grammarly premium gives
real-time suggestions on your writing so
that you can get to the next item on
your list in record time grammarly
premium helps you get your message
across quickly without repeated or
unnecessary words grammarly has helped
me catch something wrong in an email or
text document a whole bunch of times
that not only saves me time but also
keeps me from looking like a dummy to
the people i send those to with the free
version of grammarly you're safe from
embarrassing basic spelling or grammar
or punctuation mistakes grammarly
premiums advanced time-saving features
help you write more clearly and
efficiently streamline your workload
with seamless integration into microsoft
office your internet browser your phone
and more close all those thesaurus tabs
and save research time with vocabulary
suggestions for more compelling word
choices get straight to the point with
clarity suggestions that eliminate
unnecessary or redundant words and
phrases hit send with confidence and get
your point across more effectively with
grammarly premium get 20 off grammarly
premium by signing up at
grammarly.com rogue that's 20 off at
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash rogue so uh if you guys
saw this this week uh as we head into
our road question here there is a new
teaser poster for the next sonic movie
and it's going to introduce knuckles
confirmed to be voiced by idris elba
so knowing that we have we have elba in
this i want you to pitch me your
craziest idea for what you think this
movie's gonna be
i think this is the way that idris is
finally gonna get to play james bond the
first five minutes of it are gonna be
sonic and then all at once they're gonna
get dragged into another dimension and
knuckles is going to become james bond
and i might
finally
is that just my dream was that my dream
was that was just my dream okay
i feel like a lot of the sonic 2 plot is
probably gonna have to do with the uh
the creation of shadow the hedgehog
because the first movie was all about
sonic and like the government's like oh
my god who's this hedgehog so they're
probably gonna be like we have to make
our own hedgehog to fight wars because
that's what we do and so like we're
probably gonna see shadow so like what
if we get like idris elba um fighting
shadow in like this like weird like
james bond situation where like because
the shadow is like more of like a gun
badass guy so it's like idris elba
knuckles versus shadow in
james in england
in london for some reason it's just two
brothers two brothers two brothers at
odds um
that's just a fun little thing but yeah
i do want to see shadow and sauna too
because why not here's what i think okay
sonic is gonna get a letter in the mail
one day from knuckles and he's gonna be
he he knew nothing about knuckles and
he's gonna be like i'm your older
brother knuckles you left me you were
taken away as a child from the green
hill zone and now it's time for you to
come back and help me clean stuff up
around here right so sonic goes back
he's fighting with knuckles they're
cleaning up the green hill zone
everything's getting peaceful and then
sonic realizes that knuckles is really
like a tyrant running this place
[Music]
against his brother knuckles or saving
the people and telling the truth and
that's going to be like the ultimate and
then he turns into james bond and that's
the end of the movie
i think that that's got to be the case
that's gotta be it just it's beautiful
it's beautiful
but i think that's awesome
as like a hero and then reveal him to be
a villain you know what i mean i love
that empty your voice as the government
is very interesting like when you were
like the government
i was like that is how the government
sounds
that's the government i've been uh
watching a lot of c-span lately and uh
that's pretty much exclusively what they
sound like uh well i'm gonna give the
point uh to brandon for that one because
that just sounds like that sounds like
the wildest idea
knuckles uh it's emotional especially
one that spends all of its time in the
green hill zone i don't want to see the
real world anywhere put him in a
digitized world yeah i don't have to see
him make this an animated movie it's
just an animated movie or something
exactly please well uh that makes
brandon uh today's winner
congratulations
is this his first broke jerry victory
i
for always sleeping in a separate room
from me
[Laughter]
oh god i wasn't supposed to say that
always keep it in john always
ah well uh that is it for this episode
of rogue theory i want to thank all of
our guests anastasia washington
uh and mt and brandon barrick all three
of you guys were great support all of
them on social media and you can support
us here at new rockstars again by
checking out our merch at new york
source merch.com including our new uh
bad company design uh our latest
obsession you can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars here on youtube and we'll
see you next time bye everybody
[Music]
foreign